people are suffering
people are dying entire ecosystems
are collapsing we are in the beginning
of a mass
extinction and all you can talk about is
money
and fairy tales of eternal economic
growth
how dare you if you
were a time traveler wouldn't you want
to see
what's happening on earth in the next
100 years
our civilization has faced enormous
threats
bushfires earthquakes floods and
hurricanes
and we continue to face lethal pandemics
these dangers are so severe that several
scientists are concerned
that human civilization might collapse
it's a horrifying thought but what if
it's true
is human civilization on the brink of
disaster
how would it all unfold
and how long before it could all come to
an
end this is what if
and here's what would happen if
civilization
collapses in january of 2021
a paper published in frontiers in
conservative science
states that we are on a sixth
major extinction path according to the
authors
biodiversity loss climate disruption
human consumption and population growth
will soon bring us to the end of
civilization as we know it
and some physicists have calculated
a 90 chance that human society will
collapse
within decades so if we could see the
future
how might these events unfold
and how long do we have until doomsday
our starting point is covet 19.
this pandemic has killed millions
worldwide
sure we have all kinds of vaccines but
because of our ecologically
unsustainable lifestyles
scientists predict more deadly pandemics
are on the horizon
surface temperatures at the top 100
meters of the oceans
have risen by one-third of a degree
endangering 25
of biodiversity in marine life and
bleaching about 30 percent of the global
coral reefs
could this affect the food security of
millions of people
hold tight our path forward is
raising a lot of questions so
let's keep going to find out glaciers
are melting
raising global sea levels by 20
centimeters
today floods are already happening more
frequently and
rising sea levels are threatening cities
towns and villages worldwide
this raises another question would the
inhabitants of these places
have to move somewhere else the numbers
of
mammals birds reptiles and fishes
have decreased by 70 percent disrupting
the food chain and ecosystems
would that affect our diet how could we
sustain ourselves
and the next generations pollution and
consumerism are depleting the soil and
water
decreasing our air quality and affecting
what we're ingesting
if the food we eat and the water we
drink are polluted
you can bet our bodies will feel the
brunt of it
cancer deaths are steadily increasing
and they could
rise even more with the deterioration of
the environment
would you be able to avoid getting sick
the world's richest one percent own half
the wealth
this extreme inequality could increase
even more this could us by
slowing down
any measures that could help us to avoid
humanity's collapse
but if you're still optimistic and think
that
somehow everything is going to be okay
then that's great
but let's see if you're right
[Music]
seventy to ninety percent of coral reefs
would die
thousands of species and marine life
would begin to go extinct
add to this earth's increasing
temperature and it could
trigger the loss of millions of tons of
maize wheat and soybean crops
that would bring some parts of asia
south america and
africa to starvation forcing us
to change our diets drastically
as ecosystem equilibrium breaks
nature could respond with infestations
of
insects that could impact our crops even
more
millions of people who rely on fishing
and agriculture
would have to leave their homes in order
to survive
an unprecedented mass migration would
begin
maybe as several cultures already do
we would start to introduce insects into
our diet
as they would be plentiful and free
you want some ketchup with that
the earth's population would hit 10
billion by the year 2050.
overpopulation and a shortage of
resources would
inevitably bring social tensions and
poverty
ocean creatures and thousands of other
species on earth
would disappear
[Music]
sea levels would continue to rise entire
islands
could be submerged japan
indonesia the caribbean and countless
coastal areas around the world
would become history inhabitants of
these areas would have to move
inland intensifying the mass migrations
already happening and any pre-existing
conflicts
could trigger wars between countries
we've seen how refugees are being
treated
now imagine that but hundreds of times
worse
the lack of food and clean water could
worsen
and decimate our human population
we would face drought famine pandemics
and these catastrophic events would
eventually
affect everyone everywhere and chaos
would rule
that could leave us with only a few
thousand survivors
or it could lead us to total extinction
after that what would the earth look
like
human beings would leave behind
abandoned civilizations
and mountains of waste mostly
tons of plastic that won't disappear for
thousands of years
and cities would change drastically due
to the lack of maintenance
without people to maintain them sewers
wouldn't divert rainfall
or rising groundwater the subways in
massive sprawling cities like new york
london manila hong kong and mumbai
could flood within hours unmanned
nuclear
plants could trigger leaks and nuclear
meltdowns
contaminating surrounding areas
insects would take over farmland cities
and the wild that could actually be
beneficial for several other survivor
species
as the years go by buildings would
collapse from
erosion and fire glass would probably go
first
followed by metal structures that would
rust and crumble
stone buildings might weather but they
would still last for millennia
it would take millions of years for
earth to recover but
eventually it would become more lush and
diverse
new ecosystems would be in place with
both old
and newer species coexisting
of course this is only a prediction but
just look at the things that have
already happened and things that are
happening now
is there a chance that our civilization
could collapse
in the next century well we need to take
drastic measures against climate change
right now
if we don't we could be trapped at home
forever
because outside would be too hot
too polluted and there would be too many
pandemics
can you imagine what your life would be
like if
coveted 19 never went away well
that's a story for another
what if
before you go on to the next
hypothetical adventure have a look at
our what if 100 book
this is your must-have encyclopedia of
imaginations
a beautiful collection of your 100
favorite scenarios
amazing artworks and interesting facts
all in good old beautiful print and
paper
click the link below to instantly
receive a digital copy
you